To the extent that there's a positive
to take out of this whole pandemic,
it's obviously been the heroic work
of the medical professionals.
The doctors, the nurses,
the people that work
at the hospital on a day-to-day basis.
So, today, I thought we would
focus on one of these stories
and head to Houston, where I grew up,
to talk with an old elementary
school of mine, Brent Kaziny.
He's a doctor there.
He works at the Texas Children's Hospital.
And along with people on his team,
and other people at the hospital,
they came up with an open source design
for a protective system for people
who are performing intubations,
to make sure the virus
wasn't spreading in the air.
And, so with that, let's go talk to Brent
and hear his story.
Besides being an illustrious alum
of Memorial Drive Elementary,
do you mind introducing yourself
and telling us kinda
what you do over there?
Yeah, sure, so, I'm the Medical Director
of Emergency Management at
Texas Children's Hospital.
And what that really means is that just
when there are disaster
things that happen,
hurricane, flooding, what have you,
I kind of help the
organization respond to that.
Yeah, but obviously this is
quite a different situation.
Whole different ball game.
We are super prepared for hurricanes here.
We do annual drills on hurricanes
that can obviously happen annually here.
But I don't think any of us really
started laying the groundwork
for a response of this magnitude.
I mean, it's just kind of nuts
with what we're going through right now
across the country and the world.
Some of the early reports were like,
it doesn't seem to
affect children as much.
I mean, what was your experience like?
I think the good news
through this whole thing is
that kids don't seem to be as
markedly impacted as adults.
But we're now seeing these case reports,
this inflammatory disease process,
inflammatory system response
that some kids are having
and there are reports out of
New York and UK about that.
And so, we're obviously kind
of gearing up towards that
and making sure we're not
gonna miss any cases of those,
or kids that might progress to that.
And so, just kinda going back,
you started seeing some pictures
coming out of intubating people.
And I mean, tell me the story.
I think you saw these pictures
and it kinda concerned you that maybe--
Yeah, I mean, really one of the things
that we were realizing
is that our providers
that intubate regularly,
so we're putting airways in and things,
they're at high risk of exposure, right?
There are secretions, you're
suctioning all this stuff.
And people were starting
to get really freaked
out about their potential
for contracting this
illness from patients.
And so, I'd just kind of
been looking on the internet
and somebody sent me something.
It was actually a physician in Taiwan,
had made this plexiglass rectangular box
with kinda two arm holes,
and I was like, man, it's
a really interesting idea
but, I don't know that
ergonomically this would make sense
for the way that I would
put my arms and hands
and I don't know if the
access is limiting and--
So, you see in these pictures.
You're like, I don't think
this is gonna work for me.
Let's try something else.
And so, what?
Did you just literally start
sketching something out
on a piece of paper, or--
So, it started with some
paper and some sketches.
Then I literally went to
our office supply closet
and took all the paper
reams out of a cardboard box
and started hacking it up
and taping it together with duct tape.
I mean, our facilities team is amazing
and in five days we
went from cardboard box
to functional working prototype.
And so, out of this came
the Airway/Respiratory Containment System,
or the ARC as we call it.
Yeah, so, walk me
through just a little bit
of the specifics of how it works.
So, you essentially put the device
over the patient's head.
There's support holes for
personnel to get in there.
And there's two other holes
that I think are really important too.
And those holes we use to
create negative pressure.
So, we hook a viral filter
up to one of those holes
and then some tubing that you
hook up to the wall suction.
And so, it's essentially sucking...
Anything that's aerosolized
should get sucked out of there,
so it's not gonna come at you
when you take the device off, right?
So, put it on, I get in there.
I put the airway in, hook
it up to the ventilator,
take the box off and it's
ready for the next patient.
We're not trying to make money off of it.
There's no IP.
It's an open source project
that we're just sharing with the world.
You guys open sourced so basically
that means you just
put up the CAD drawings
or the specs--
Yeah.
And everything behind it?
There's a company called,
I think it's called Sawbones, right?
That's actually, they're making it?
Yeah, so they tweaked our final design.
They kind of made a professional CAD of it
and now they have it on their website.
If you want to download the sketch
and make it yourself in your wood shop,
just like we did, you can
or you can buy one from
them and it's 130 bucks.
And this is the device you guys are using
in the hospital on kind
of day-to-day basis?
Yeah, so, we've got four
and they're being used
in the operating rooms
across the institution now.
Have other hospitals heard about this yet?
Have they been able to order some as well?
It's all happening so quickly.
I think there's interest.
You know, I think in healthcare
and in particular
hospital based healthcare,
we tend to be lagging when it comes
to innovation and technology.
And my hope is that in
the in the post COVID era,
we'll be able to use things like this
as an example and say,
look guys, we pushed this
through and got it done.